2018년도에 한 117억 정도의
매입을 한 다음에 근데 매입할 때
대출을 거의 100억 가까이
받았습니다 그 2021년도에
210억원에 팔았어요
[음악]
제가 오늘은
야구 선수분들의 빌딩을 한번 제가
종합적으로 모아서 한번 좀 설명을
드릴 건데 제가 최근에 최강 야구에
빠졌습니다
매주 기다리느라고 정말 힘들 정도로
너무 팬인데 최강 야구의 그 김성근
감독님도 빌딩을 좀 가지고 계시거든요
김성근 감독님 빌딩도 한번 좀 보고
다른 야구 선수분들은 어떻게 빌딩
투자를 했는지 제가 오늘 설명드리도록
하겠습니다 김성근 감독님은 원래
성수동의 주택이 있었어요 주택이
90년도 초반에 이제 매입을 해
가지고 그걸 이제 주택조합의 메가
그랬거든요 여기 일대인데 여기 안에
이제 주택을 가지고 있다가 그거를
주택조합에 135억에 매각을 했습니다
그 이쪽을 전체적으로 다 개발해야
되기 때문에 그 가격에 이제 매각을
했었고 그리고 이제 매각한 다음에
바로 앞에 있는 건물을
매입을 했어요 그래서 지금 여기
보이는 되게 유명한
커피숍이죠네 그래서 여기
이 건물
원래 전에 건물이 이거였습니다 원래
그 이시형님이
가지고 있던 건물을 매입을 한 거예요
이시영님이 원래 이제이 건물을
샀다가 뒤에 것까지 같이 샀거든요요
두 필지를 김성근 감독님이
80억 원의 매입을 했습니다 그리고이
건물 같은 경우에는
준주거지역이에요 준주거지역 용적률을
최대 400%까지 받을 수 있습니다
근데 여기 건너편에 아뜰리에 길은
여기가 준주건 아니에요 다 이제 2종
아니면 3종이 있는데 김성근 감독님이
가지고 있는 거는
준주거지역입니다 그래서
땅의 가치가 굉장히 좀 좋은 건물이고
건물이 한 4 5층 정도 되지만
건물을 올렸을 때 뭐 거의 10층
가까이 올릴 수 있을 것 같아요
토지 활용도가 굉장히 높은 건물이고
그리고요 일대 워낙 또 비싸게 계속
매각이 되가고 있어 가지고 지금
시세도 좀 상당히 많이 올랐습니다
근데 제가 금액은 언급 안 할게요
혼날 수도 있으니까
점수로 봤을 때는 굉장히 투자를 잘
하시는 거 같습니다 그래서
뿐만 아니라 이런 투자 쪽도 굉장히
좀 잘 하시는 것 같아요 뭐 워낙
여기이 가게가 너무 잘 됩니다
당장 짚거나 그럴 거 같진 않은데
나중에 어차피 뒤에 거랑 같이 지을
만한 투자 가치도 있어서 저는 뭐
가지고 있기에는 너무 좋은
빌딩 같습니다 이승엽
님 건물이요 앞에 있어요 대로변에
원래 전에 에스콰이에 들어와 있던 거
이거를
2009년도에 샀습니다 그래서
293억 원의 매입해서 아직까지
가지고 있어요 그때 당시에는 되게
말이 많았어요 야 그때 당시에는 여기
아무것도 없었거든요 다 이제 공장지
되고 그래서 잘못 산 거 아니냐 뭐
이런 얘기들이 굉장히 많았는데 최근에
성수동이 굉장히 핫해지면서이 건물의
가치도 수직 상승하고 있습니다
장기로
2009년도에 사실 여기 투자하기가
쉽지 않았을 것 같은데 그때 당시
293억원 엄청 큰 돈이죠 그래서
이걸로 투자를 해서 지금까지 가지고
있고
요것도 시세가 굉장히 많이 올랐어요
거의 몇 배 올랐습니다 김성근
감독님은 이면에 있고 이승엽 님은
이제 대로변 코너에 위치하고 그리고
또 야구 선수 중에 한 분이 제가
팬인 kt죠
kt에 그 황재균 선수분이
방이동의 건물이 있었어요 여기 잠실역
건너편에 방이동에
2018년도에 한 117억 정도의
매입을 한 다음에 근데 매입할 때
대출을 거의 100억 가까이
받았습니다 그 2021년도에
210억원에 팔았어요 그리고 여기
근처로 또 이사하셨더라고요 그 제일
높은 건물에 우리나라 제일 높은 건물
신혼집이 그쪽인지는 잘 모르겠어요
거기도 매입하시고이 방이동 건물은
지금 매각한 것으로 좀 보여집니다
그리고 또 야구 선수 중에 또 사신
분이 그 김현수 선수네 그분은 이제
교대역에 여기가 땅의 가치가 그래도
상업지에요 상업지에 위치한 건물 두
필지를
매입을 했고요 김현수 선수 같은
경우에는 113억에 매입을 했고 아마
제가 봤을 때 지금 건물이 높지
않아서
지을 것 같습니다 그리고 저는 야구
선수 중에
투자 제일 잘한 일등은 누구냐라고
얘기 를 한다면
박찬호 선수입니다
박찬호 선수분은 여기 신사역이랑
을지병원 사거리요 사이에 도산대로
변해 건물을 지었어요네 건물을 지었고
지금이 건물입니다 렉서스 들어간
엄청 높죠 그래서이 건물이
원래 중국집이 들어가 있던 건물이었던
것 같아요 이렇게 멸실한 다음에
신축을 했습니다 제가 제일 좋아하는
도로에 제일 갖고 싶은 건물 중에
하나입니다
빌딩 전문가가 제일 좋아하는
건물입니다
꿈 같은 건물 여기 이면에 보면은
이렇게
뒤에랑 이렇게 약간 연결되어 있고 어
박찬호님이 제가 봤을 때는
빌딩
투자하는데 있어서
야구선수 분들 중에는 최고입니다 저는
1위가
박찬호님 그리고 2위가 2승이 없는
황재균 선수 아직 하고 있으니까
선수분은
시세 차이가 많이 남겼고 근데 이제
세금 떼고 하면은 실제 차익이 뭐
줄어들긴 하겠지만 어찌됐든 투자를
굉장히 좀 잘 했고 그 김성근
감독님도 너무 잘하셨습니다 왜 이렇게
다들 잘하죠 야구선수분들
땅의 가치가 워낙 좋아서 나중에 이제
개발할 여지도 있고 김현수 님도
그것도 나중에 이제 좀 개발할 여지가
있기 때문에 그것도 뭐 투자 잘 한
것으로 좀 보여집니다
그래서 제가 봤을 때는 야구
선수분들이 은근 투자를 되게 잘했네요
제가 또 보니까 또 몇몇 이제 그
금액대가 크지 않은 건물들을 또
강남에 몇 군데 샀거든요 그분들 투자
사례도 봐도 되게 좀 좋은 위치에 잘
매입한 사례들이 꽤 있어요 그래서
대체적으로 좀 투자를 잘 하시는 것
같습니다 그리고 김성근 감독님은 저
완전 팬입니다 너무
정말 아버지 같은 그 야구 선수들에게
뭔가
묵묵하지만
뭔가 프로다한 느낌도 너무 많이 나고
너무 격려도 너무 잘해주시고
그래가지고
빌딩 투자까지 잘해서 되게
놀랬습니다네 그래서 오늘 영상
여기까지 하고요
다음 시간에 또 뵙도록 하겠습니다
감사합니다